Speaker 1: The the grift continues.
Actually, it's not even really the grift.
It's more the is it the cover up a we now
have a new report.
That the gift records for Donald Trump and
Mike Pence, they're just missing.
They're gone.
The State Department says.
NBC News reporting.
The Executive Office of the President did
not submit information about gifts received
by Trump and his family from foreign leaders
in the year 2020.
This is a this is quite literally how you
track the emoluments adherence to the emoluments
clause of the Constitution.
You know, when we talk about people in office
receiving gifts and things of value from foreigners,
this was an issue during the Russia investigation.
This is how we track it.
This is how we hold them accountable for 2020.
The records are just missing.
The article goes on to say the State Department
says it is unable to compile a complete and
accurate accounting of gifts presented to
Trump and other officials during his last
year in office.
The data is missing from the White House and
a report to be published in the Federal Register
next week.
The department says the Executive Office of
the President did not submit information about
gifts received by Trump and his family from
foreign leaders in 2020.
Wow.
It also says the General Services Administration
didn't submit information about gifts given
to Mike Pence and staffers.
The State Department said it sought the missing
information from where from the National Archives
and Records Administration and the GSA, but
was told that quote potentially relevant records
are not available because of access restrictions
to retired records.
Speaker 4: Wow.
Speaker 1: The report notes the lack of gift
information could be related to internal oversights,
as the protocol office neglected to submit
the request prior to Bah Bah Bah Bah Bah.
When the Trump administration ended, however,
it also noted there has been a quote.
This is like the understatement of the century.
There's been a lack of adequate record keeping
pertaining to diplomatic gifts during Trump's
White House reign.
I mean, listen, maybe check Mar a Lago for
those records as well?
I don't know.
And now there are there.
There's the reaction.
Oh, everybody does this, this this or every
administration?
Does this?
Actually, no.
Go back to the Guardian report.
From 2018, we learned that the Saudis gave
Barack Obama and his aides jewels worth thousands
of dollars, according to ex adviser Ben Rhodes.
They got quote suitcases full of jewels on
a 2009 trip, and they were immediately turned
over to the state protocol office.
No missing records, no question marks.
We know exactly what went on.
This is this is a big difference here.
Between the two administrations and, you know,
it's one of these things where individually,
well, the documents that Trump ate, he ate
because they thought they tasted like Doritos.
And so you don't have to worry about that
and the documents he flushed.
Thought they might have E. coli on them and
Trump wanted to get them out of there.
And then the documents that he brought to
Mar a Lago.
Right?
I mean, I'm kidding around about the explanations,
but that there's the individual.
You can say this was an oversight and that
was an accident.
And then Trump ripped him up because that's
what he's used to.
But we taped them back together.
But then you take the totality and you have
to say, this is a pattern.
And one of the things that investigators look
at.
You know, we talk about there are crimes that
are really difficult to prove because they
go to state of mind.
I know this is like a broken record, but perjury.
People lie in court all the time.
And sometimes the lies are really hard to
prove.
Like, for example, there is a technique where
you can go in when you're supposed to give
testimony and your your you testify in court
and you're asked about things and you don't
want to lie, you don't want to give a false
answer.
So you say you don't recall.
Now, sometimes saying you don't recall can
get you into trouble because good lawyers
that are prepared for false I don't recalls,
have a line of questioning and they have records
and they can actually show you did recall
when someone else asked you about it or whatever.
So sit lying about, I don't recall, has its
risks.
But sometimes for a well-prepared witness,
dishonest I don't recalls, can get you out
of trouble and you are lying.
You do recall, and it's very hard to prove,
and that's why you rarely see perjury charges.
OK.
Just one example.
When it comes to,
Speaker 4: um,
Speaker 1: sedition, for example, sedition.
And maybe I can even pull up the definition
of conduct or speech meant to incite people
to rebel against an authority, OK, you know.
So with sedition, there's an aspect of saying,
Well, it's not only what you said, but it
was your intent in getting people to rebel
against the established order or the government
or what.
These things can be can be difficult to prove,
but context and a pattern is something that
can be used to try to show what was in the
mindset of an individual.
And when you see all the things Trump knew
were wrong, right?
He said Hillary is irresponsible with with
sensitive information and private email and
not keeping records, so he knew that these
things were wrong to do.
And then Trump rips up records its records,
flushes, records, steals records, spills,
secrets to a Russian spy recruiter in the
Oval Office that we got from our ally, Israel.
You see the pattern of him doing things which
we know he knew they were wrong because he
criticized Hillary for doing them.
Then it's hard to say that this isn't a pattern
and that this is deliberate action.
Right?
I mean, it just is what it is.
Will there be consequences?
Probably not.
But I do have a voicemail that goes to that.
Let's go to
that next.